85 km plus au nord julie et et ludovic
ont hissé la grand voile
enfin ils ont sorti les pagaies et
affronte un petit bras de loire le rio
[Musique]
on va vraiment longer le plus possible
le bord pour le moins de courant
possible le rio c'est un chenal qui sert
d'entraînement aux novices ça tombe bien
juliette al'étoffe d'une débutante et
découvre la notion de balades sportives
j'ai cru entendre un oiseau là tu vois
souvent des des animaux voilà en fait on
and on est dans un écosystème toi donc
non même le futur dans le futur parc de
loire d'orléans
donc du coup on va beaucoup de l'oiseau
des martins pêcheurs
oui
évidemment le paddle c'est avant tout un
sport mais la pratique en rivière
présente les avantages de la maîtrise
des courants pita bus suivant le rythme
qu'on se donne en fait là on est
vraiment sur un rythme tranquille il ya
peu de contraintes musculaire ou quoi
quand même continuer à travailler
musculairement
mais en fait c'est à chacun son rythme
c'est ça qui est le paddle sait qu'on
peut le faire vraiment le faire d'une
façon sportive
ouais vous voulez faire vraiment mode
ballade loisirs d'ailleurs ludovic
organise fréquemment des sessions
dédiées à la flânerie les participants
de 7 à 77 ans
c'est hyper agréable on est au calme en
plus c'est trop bien
j'adore aggrave ouais c'est encore plus
beau plus aux tueurs
et puis je te préparer une petite
surprise pour cet après midi aussi donc
à découvrir à tout à l'heure qui vous
fait peur oui la suite du programme
promet une belle accélération
enfin si on évite la noyade avant la fin
c
[Musique]